one of the things that I've seen lately
is that a lot of numbers are showing
that the black community has not gotten
any better economically under the seven
years of Obama and you know people felt
you know he wanted to sort of be a
post-racial president I don't think
we've quite got there not necessarily
his fault but what can the black
community to get those numbers well I
don't necessarily agree with those
statistics I think they're there if you
depending on what you read the economy
overall is much better under Obama
millions more however that the economy
itself it the economy itself is but that
the black community still is well behind
in that sort of regrowth the black
community has made some gains under
Obama so again I disagree with and I
reject those statistics that say blacks
are worse off under Obama than they were
under George Bush hello I don't think so
do we still have a ways to go in this
country absolutely are we still
disproportionately impacted by a
criminal justice system yes are we still
lagging behind in wages in asset
accumulation absolutely so there is a
lot of work to be done but that doesn't
dismiss the great work that President
Obama has done on health care look at
the jobs rate the unemployment rate
lower than it's been in a decade so I
think we have to celebrate those prot
you know the advances that have been
made and keep fighting over coming
hundreds of years of systemic racism
obviously what we are now seeing doesn't
happen overnight it is a long and
entrenched fight that is I think what we
learn more intractable than perhaps what
we thought I don't think anyone thought
that Obama's legacy yeah you know the
hope we were all high on hope years ago
hi-yah hi-yah oh yeah and no one could
have predicted that the rank R and the
adversarial nature of what he has faced
particularly in these last three years I
I know I couldn't imagine yeah and saw
that right and it's hard to say is that
is that racial is that that our system
is just warped would would the
Republicans have been more willing to
work with the white president I hate
bringing everything down to that to that
point there may be some element of it I
don't think we really know I don't think
we know yeah I don't think we can ever
and again i get so beat up about this
but it's just what I know just
historically I'm a student of history
race matters in this country no matter
whether you're the president united
states or you're the president of the
oscars the fact that we're still
fighting these battles have to tell us
that race still matters so yeah all
right let's get how about we get away
from racing okay let's get away from me
it's just it's such a shame that we have
to spend so much yeah talking about it
but that that is the point I suppose so
let's talk about politics because I know
you're hanging in the politics thing to
you are supporting Hillary I am
supporting Hillary Clinton I'm also
supporting a slew of progressive and
some female mostly female candidates i'm
a big proponent of inclusion not just
for race for women for LGBTs for latinos
i just think this country works better
our state our city our county when we
have diverse voices so I support a lot
of candidates at the local state and
national level that don't look like
traditional candidates so what do you
make of the Hillary campaign because
I've I'm not sure who I'm supporting at
this point I'm really still I've become
really at this point I see myself as a
real centrist and I'm just not sure now
it seems to me that Hillary and Bernie
are way better than any Republican I
their debates have been about substance
you know they've really even with the
the gun thing you know the Hillary's
trying to pin Bernie as the gun guy
meanwhile he got a d-minus from the NRA
but so it's really been about substance
the Republicans it'sit's drunk all its
and silliness we can talk about that too
but one thing I have seen with Hillary
is that to me this campaign because of
the email stuff and then Ghazi which
finally that's going away but whatever
it is but there is no there hasn't been
a point where it's been like a run like
a nice like month-long
run where this is about really feeling
good and maybe that's the media doesn't
like her I don't think the media really
likes her something but how do you feel
about the campaign in general so here's
what I think I think the the Trump and
the outsider voices that have dominated
the news media isn't just impacting GOP
and the Republicans it's also impacting
dimms as well and bernie is lining up as
that outside voice and Hillary of course
is the mainstream establishment
candidate when you listen to what Bernie
and Hillary are saying knowing what we
now know about Obama Bernie's policies
they just don't have a snowball's chance
in hell of ever coming to fruition he's
talking about a ninety percent tax rate
on the ridge hello so it's a rich guys
in Congress and Senate are gonna vote
for ninety percent tax rate oh yeah I
have to I have to jump because I know
people are gonna be yelling at you over
that because I've mentioned that and
people have said to me what he's saying
is that it would be a progressive tax so
it's not that you're being taxed fully
on the ninety percent you know it is
right shirred mark increase on the rich
it doesn't play well to Congress because
most those guys are rich guys he's
talking about eliminating Obamacare a
single source single payer source health
care system we couldn't get that voted
in even when the Congress was controlled
by dimms so I like his fire I like his
progressive politics but I'm a
pragmatist at heart and I just don't
think any of those things he could get
accomplished and we don't need eight
more years of not being able to get
anything accomplished what I like about
Hillary is she setting me on fire am I
as high as I was eight years ago on hope
yeah you don't have that tangle of you
later I don't have any of that yeah but
at the core of me I like getting stuff
done I think the woman can get done
is that and you talk about the Benghazi
and the emails to me the crowning joy of
her campaign was sitting at those
hearings for you life are her best
moment the way they attacked her it
would have taken mother Teresa herself
to to restrain some of these junior just
got to Congress five days ago don't know
where the bathroom is yeah people
yelling at her about the most ridiculous
and unimportant details and she just SAT
there I so I'm with you a hundred
percent that was not only was her best
moment to me was like you should be the
president just for that i posted a
really funny vine did you see there was
a moment where she did this little thing
she was so look away like it was like
drop the mic well and it was like vote
that's the kind of level headed yeah
toughness that you need in office and
that's what to me Bernie when Bernie is
doing I'm like dual okay you got to
bring it down a notch you yelling I
can't really understand you you're
making you get your give Manning so it's
interesting because i know so a lot of
my audience loves Bernie and I've said
several times that me my heart I like
Bernie the best I like the idea is the
best but I also because I consider
myself a pragmatist when he's saying
these things sometimes I see what he
tweets these really lofty things about
you know it's all about changing the
system i'm all for changing the system
and getting money out of politics and
all those things but we just had obama
try to change the system pretty
intensely too and we were all higher
than oh my grandma hi seven years ago
right so that's that's why at this point
I sort of think I mostly but grudgingly
supporting Hillary but right up to
because here's the problem with that and
I try to tell people this with Obama
nobody would listen to me Vinny oh my
god sense to me yeah that's okay that's
well that's what my clients pay me a
thousand now but note we have a
two-party system and the president is
here he can do nothing she can do
nothing without the Congress and the
Senate you could be the most Charis you
cannot have been more charismatic than
Obama the guy is like swag on steroids
yeah but that doesn't mean anything in
Washington DC and that's the problem
with all these people following Trump
Trump is not going to be a dictator we
don't have a dictatorship in our
government our government is about it's
a collaborative and if you're not able
one to understand that and then to to
navigate that you get
nothing done so that's the crazy part
and where it goes to in this I think is
probably a through line of everything
we've said here is that education is the
most important part we have we have
three branches of government people
forget that we have a judicial branch
they decide what's legal we've a
legislative branch they decide to make
laws and then we have all these
immigration policies these these GOP
candidates are talking about they're
going to build a wall and they're gonna
how exactly you're gonna do that so that
to me is the most dangerous pilot stuff
come for a second because I saw him say
a week ago or two weeks ago he said
something like when I'm president you
know they're gonna put Merry Christmas
back on starbucks coffee or something
like that now I get it it's just a
stupid he's just throwing stupid red
meat out to to some morons like even
that it shows it shows a inclination to
not even really understand what the role
of the president is and they've dumb it
down if you watch those GOP debates I'm
sitting in their foreign power when ben
Carson said see my mother used to drive
a car until the car wouldn't drive
anymore this she would take her pennies
and she'd buy a new car well he somehow
supposed to translate to economic policy
of the world yeah welcome harder pennies
do well I uh Isis oh yeah well they said
well you hit one of the questions like
well you can't bomb these these these
vehicles because they have civilians
well just tell them if they ride in a
car they're gonna get bomb so they
shouldn't get in a car so that's the
that's the piece yeah that's a piece
yeah I mean look that's not a policy on
Isis that is stupidity and that's the
piece that goes across both sides
because so you hear that a righty here
ben Carson and it's like you clearly
know nothing about foreign policy like
he just uses a couple buzzwords
Caliphate jihad like he just puts a
couple words together but then I'll here
Bernie talk about it and I'm not for war
I'm certainly not for nation building
and all that stuff but I hear him say
well you know we're gonna have to work
with our allies do this but but he also
will say I'm never for war which means
that there's no
threat of anything to so it's like both
sides are playing as that's the scary
part and that's what I think the worst
thing about the Trump reality show is it
has dummy down the conversation so that
we're starting to believe that these
blusterous you know blow horns can go in
with these simplistic solutions to these
complex I mean the problems are so
complex so his whole Muslim policy do
you know that the people who are
fighting Isis the most or Muslims so
when you insult the Muslim community
you're insulting our outside but but if
you don't know anything about foreign
policy you don't know that yeah and now
what's really scary me as they're saying
on Trump becomes a GOP nominee he's got
a now somehow figure out how to reverse
himself you know he's insulted
african-americans Latinos Muslims just
about every group that you need to win
the general election in this country
yeah so now he's gotta walk that but how
do you walk that back and here's his
dilemma if he walks it back those white
lower middle-class men mostly who are
supporting him they're gonna be pissed
they're gonna be pissed because the
reason they like him is because he's
standing up to make America great ie
white again so how do you embrace the
immigrant population in the Muslim
population without alienating your base
and that's the stupidity of the GOP
party to me yeah you know it's
interesting this is where I've been very
critical of the left because I think
that the progressives because they so
their intentions usually are very good
but they're Sony their knee-jerk
responses to yell bigot or racist or
homophobic sexist or whatever it is at
everybody that they in a way they've
enabled Trump because they've silent so
many centrists and so many liberals that
I think they've enabled well then Trump
just comes in with answers instead of
saying instead of a real debate where we
say what are we really doing with
immigration right now what are we really
doing about refugees and migrants Trump
just comes in and says I'm banning
everybody and then that sounds good so I
partly do blame our side of the aisle on
that well because we have
dealt with it well so that narrow group
of people that he plays sue but I one of
the things I find most interesting about
the GOP I'll actually remember after
mitt romney lost they went and did this
exhaustive audit mm-hmm how did we lose
let's dissect let's analyze and figure
out what happened and what they conclude
it was they did not garner enough votes
from the minority voters particularly
latinos and that they had to become the
party of inclusion and so and in all
their bigger need owner said we're no
longer supporting any of these cooks we
want candidates that can win we're going
to put our money behind candidates that
can win and we're going to go out and
become the party of inclusion and
they've done the exact opposite yeah
frontrunner not runner runners have made
the concept of inclusion like a joke
you